o lago só de quem falar que sejam muito
bem vindos ao prêmio ensino médio de
não vi o vídeo traz mais gastar meu para
olha tu pagas com essas piadas e isso
não tem graça já há quem só seguir o
primeiro vídeo e 2020 e não e vejam só
como está o quarto onde chegou muitas
encomendas show e desvenda muita coisa
lá dentro também foi ao local só que com
mais misteriosa também só para a
regulação atrair muitos de vocês já
descobriram que a voz misteriosa ela no
instagram dá muita gente falar jogos eu
sei que não estou mas estou super
ansiosa
portanto deixe muito líquidos filho que
em breve em breve em breve em breve eu
vou guardar que voz misteriosa caiu de
coisa só nós tivemos aqui uma magnífica
que é deixar a bola enfim só fique uma
queda deixar que nos foram super
simpático e esse filho não está sendo
paga ok eu simplesmente enviaram esta
cadeira pra mim eu estou aqui mostrar
pra vocês e para isso olha aqui para
mostrar sua beleza
leia aqui e aqui construiu essa aí é só
pessoal ela que dera eu não estou
dizendo isso só porque os não ser uma
câmera quer mas ela realmente
confortável em comparação às outras duas
é incrível eu só gostava que fosse maior
chacón por favor envie uma câmera maior
que 1 x é lula quem sabe uma coisa assim
gordinho nem mas é bem confortável
qualquer pessoa vou deixar o site o
documento muitos já cumpriu duas outras
todas do mesmo também vai confortável
porque só estou fazendo aqui
lexington no leque meu por cento diz
parece uma amiga de férias em miami mas
lá fora está a subir pois só o chaco não
é só passar no site pra ele embaixo
documento a cair embora mais obriga que
caiu para 22 mil e vinte espero que esta
caixa atm coisas muito interessantes
aqui dentro mas vai fazer porque eu só
recomendo vocês já sabem 50 coisas daqui
né mas mostrava alguma chance no caminho
eu penso eu gosto de coisas inúteis
porque eu consigo usar pra mim
curiosa quando vai começar a primeira
o evento aí não sei quem eu quero faça
já tem toda é porque vocês confiam na
encomenda do álcool não foi o juro
chinesas ou encomendar droga e ainda por
cima são vocês vendem que desconfia que
o governo eu acho que o [ __ ] nave pipa
revelados em suas encomendas a mente
gastando milhões ao deixá lo porque é
verdade isso não é coisa qual é que
mesmo nas minhas coisas e profissão sabe
bem disso e faz o que quer e nem está
dentro dos ovos o que ultimamente tem
estado então tá como hits que é uma
doença no ouvido é uma infecção terem da
gatinha camarim mas não taxe muitos
sócios quiserem ter vindo escolheu como
vai votar em baixo
obrigado fluxo não é comida dos
funcionários o que não é comida
o primeiro vai ter calma não é comigo já
o juke para não estragar um vídeo tá com
fome o alimento tudo isto é feito em
local mais mãe eu sou manhã fui atômica
limpa não quer que a toda hora só que
estamos aqui se faz aqui uma vaquinha
olha que fofa agora porque eu compreendi
que não é fácil
palmas o que tava valor vai largura
estatal
ayman shoko isso é incrível júri o
melhor brinquedo forçado a todos
interessados em uma das vagas
acho engraçado eu acho que é muito
barato então eu só comprei para lá
próxima encomenda
eu quero sim de uma embalagem escura
caixa e sacar shopping também quer que
eu fique
op que desenvolve instalados lá e falei
que certa equipe pulou mas suhaimi
escola que foi muito louco
olha só a vitória como muito porque
comprei porque eu quero fazer a ressalva
ok é eu vou fingir cozinhar um ovo e os
olhos pra cima dela
tecnicamente não vai ser testado em
outros feridos em uma tira assim com o
futebol e os instalados dois novos
benefícios mas com isso o dólar ou pior
coisa que eu sofri
então é embora fique uma caixa grande eu
gostei desta decisão assim ó alguma
coisa mais rígida uma coisa mais
phishing ver que é que recomendo tanta
coisa que eu acho que são do que uma
vítima que se encontra o está muito bom
para o está muito bom som dentro com
problema dentro durante o que não é uma
dentadura qualquer estão uma dentadura
dos clubes ter uma daquelas próprias
para os médicos aprenderam a mexer em
dentes para os alunos que estão a
estudar e talvez da medicina dentária ou
com amigos assim para perceber como
funcionam os dentes eu encomendei uma
prótese modo deles né e vamos lá então
entender como funcionam dentro dos meus
olhos não quer ser dentro só quero saber
como é que a gente funciona lá e tava
real
olha isso ó tá muito final como podem
ver que só tem aqui todo tipo de eventos
aqui tem uma vez inflamada lhe também
uma região inflamada com carne aqui tem
uma prótese com parafuso estudante aqui
olha aí
é uma prótese este deve ser também ou
sai tudo são duas próteses ajax visa
também ao senhor metros por rui cunha
filho é importante um pouco a lei
mourinho vai entrar um próxima encomenda
para uma uma arma qualquer marmanjo iner
forma uma vez só sempre gezoon o jovem
já que o piso também só eu tinha um som
daqueles mas caíram aqui é só mesmo mas
ele luxa país um exemplo de facto aliar
essa potência dele é de 665 lm não faz
idéia do que isto é mais uma presença
menos em um sem número de transações que
falta de caminhões nos gols na confusão
obrigado a resgatar o animal não chova
banho maria neto tomou regaton campos
agora não é assim a liga toda mas massa
muitas armas de neve tenha entrado aqui
para acessórios e vamos vencer esta casa
que entrou é só apertar aqui eu acho que
ela ficasse um pouco a carga mesmo
porque não é muito visada
mas tecnicamente isso ele isto não faz
mal conseguia sair perfeito encaixe
mesmo cai então só vou contar aqui por
esse lugar
a bala acertou a 321 claro que não andam
que eu vou fazer eu sinto eu vou contar
pra quê
mas mais um pouco em baixo da gezoon
[Música]
funciona vai lá mas funcionaria melhor
se tivesse aqui em cima mais perto é
mais uma encomenda pequena e que é uma
daquelas coisas que o primeiro atua não
faz idéia do que seja assim que 50 cent
será um lado uma coisa espião ok o twizy
pilha sépsis pneus para este equipamento
não faz idéia do que isto é mas vamos
ver o papel
a lei só de stress além daquelas imagens
que corre muito no pinto nessas imagens
aqui seguintes com luz sem uma luz led
para acelerar essa segunda ação militar
vamos lá galera talita que tocou meu
deus meu colo e feliz como se imagina
com um propósito não é nada meu corpo é
incrível a quetzal vai testar isso nos
colocaram aqui pilhas eu acho que minhas
filhas ali dentro do governo o cientista
que é cientista tem sempre pilhas à
disposição eu sei que o quilo mas pode
ser com o meu carro
uau tv que o equipamento com pilhas e
pode alegar 31 não você olha só que
vamos testar a minha casa vai cair
qualquer pessoa que está à nossa
excelente o inda magnífica ou olá eu dei
passando então a lógica é só colocar
assim com as queixas não vai tocando num
brutal o uso daquelas sanita incrível
estou muito feliz aqui mais uma caneta
sozinha mas é uma criança especial a
questão é uma criança qualquer é essa
aqui também é tecido ora uma coisa
barata o que nós temos aqui uma caneta
na mão direita mas acho que porque ela
tem duas pontas e porque semestre as
duas contas para fazer um pouco mais e
eu vou fazer agora o que eu tenho que
matou 20 euros e juntos vamos fazer a
toque bem é bem útil até o este grande
estilo ousado jovem aberto inclusive
tercera que queria privatizar viu eu
acho que são pedro para fazer a
discussão tem outro nome inglês chama se
segue no cheque 60 cheques acho que é
isso é a lei
[Música]
acho que o caixa usando isso como phelps
que gosta de animal é assim né
sim o uai
meu deus cuja companhia holding não
fiquei eu fui na área depois foi mais
uma loja em pequeníssima porque nem cima
vai haver também o que tem que dentro de
um bicho aqui dentro bastante forte é
satisfação garantida sem estrelas o que
é isto
outra coisa que recomenda a não esticar
para fazer uma pré cop que é um inseto
mas existem sete que é muito realista eu
tenho pelo mesmo o bicho bicho é
incrível tem um espigão eu acho que é um
acessório fashion que é para buscar
nesta prática de pesca e os pais pensam
que é mesmo o inseto quando tentam comer
agora não sei que o sol está muito
reunião para próxima encomenda esta acho
que por último neste vídeo ainda outra
que vem pra cá eu sei que nunca clique
em links também e vem tudo aberto com
isso dagoberto o botafago compatível com
os hits alguma coisa que eu não entendo
a ontem que o olha aí uma caixinha do
mario roque e o que é que traz tensão
importa jogos não é exatamente um toque
de esforços para colocar os jogos da
nintendo city e basicamente se vocês não
perdem os nossos jogos e eu não sei
porque comprei porque não tenho
ok eu não tenho nintendo não hesita em
3d
se quiser você não sai para o consumidor
será eu acho que compreende por abordar
os cartões sd da tv 3d esta uma lava e
oferece uma prendinha para mas mostrei a
última encomenda aqui no ilê aiyê nem
querer bem que nem aécio também chamou a
menos isso
dobby xodó acham que o chico que casa
que os hábitos ultrassônicos ficam só os
que conseguem ouvir por isso etapas e
não funciona bem porque eu acho que
somos o que consegue ouvir então vamos
ver se tem alguma reação
[Música]
eu acho que vou fazer um vídeo
específico só de estar porque eu não sei
se o carro funciona eu vou investigar se
sente fisicamente funciona ser correto
se realmente tem ondas ultra-sônicas
agora eu vou fazer uma investigação
primeiro aprender um pouco sobre isso
depois vamos testar porque eu tenho
rocha aqui antes deve ter várias
freqüências não protege o sportv pizza
oficiais e isso pode não funcionar como
é então eu vou investigar esse pessoal
isso que ela que foi barrado e vou fazer
um vídeo específico só ver o
comportamento do sul que com isto pinto
ultrassônico é e só neste vídeo os
bonequinhos de escombros que os vida o
estoque o que eu mais gostei foi
claramente as matracas e à luz pra ela
citou as transexuais em anos da cnn e da
incrível sol já estava impaciente também
a quina charco no shopping pela rua e
cadeirinha porque é bem confortável que
só pretende evitar que o irã fique na e
até a próxima
deus